very special guest indeed the co-founder
of the St Louis chess club Mr Rex
sinfield Rex first of all welcome to the
show we've had so many amazing matches
so far oh it's been incredible and we've
had the best commentary in the world of
all time we're always nice about that
thank you very much I'm always honest
about it what was your favorite match oh
I'll put you on the spot
I guess it would be one of the games
with Fabi well this last one was
interesting but it was pretty clear it
was Editor to draw that match I would
assume is the one that went all the way
to Armageddon yes between himself and
Levon now tell us a bit about this
format because I know you have your
doubts but right now no I like it and
I've been querying many people and I
haven't seen anybody that doesn't like
it some of them have a little trouble
understanding it at first and that's
understandable especially if you're in
the midst of it but I think it's
generated a lot of excitement and it
hasn't been used very often so people
are saying why don't we try it in all of
our other tournaments well that's a bit
you know a bit much but if you would
play in the tournament which time
control do you think would suit you the
best uh if my opponent got no time
involved yes
guys join the conversation
that's fair Rex I tell you one of the
things that's bugging me about the St
Louis chess club these days is uh the
the renovation let's let's face it the
renovation has been ongoing for the
better part of a year I know the
pandemic
but I have seen the designs and they're
beautiful and so I'm anxious for the
club to meet the expectations that
everybody has when is it going to happen
well thank you for your anxiety
we're all frustrated too it's been going
on it's like
age-old had never I I don't say it
doesn't come to an end because it hasn't
begun and that's the frustration we have
all the contracts signed all the
approvals from the city and we just
can't seem to get the contractors to
move that's the frustration I see so
that's the hold up because the the
designs are beautiful I mean it's going
to be it's going to be the most
beautiful chess club uh well certainly
America's ever seen but we want to say
the world
probably in the world but I haven't gone
to see all of them
next time I was curious to know what is
the big ambition for St Louis chess club
it's hard to hear what is the big
ambition for the Saint Louis jazz club
she's asking oh my goodness because you
guys have already done so I think they
just keep doing the things we've been
doing it would be nice someday to hold a
world championship here but I think we
have to have a St Louis participant to
justify that
Rex congratulations for this amazing new
tournament the American Cup at the
workshops Hall of Fame there's also the
music series happening every week tell
us a bit about that that happens twice a
month we have one pop Series
so it can be Seoul it can be jazz or
whatever and then we have one classical
series which I will admit is my favorite
and we often borrow performers from the
St Louis Symphony and these folks really
know their tune they're outstanding I
have to say I've been to some of those
shows they're just simply remarkable
Jovi you have something for us as we go
on a break yes we do because the World
Chess Hall of